so welcome back this is going to be the
second upload of the day if you happen
to miss the previous video you can check
the description or it'll be at the end
of the video for you to check out we did
talk about the characters and today's
video is going to be all about the maps
so show you guys the trailer for each of
them and then we'll discuss these
afterwards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
those are the trailers though those do
look really very pretty and very amazing
but Sentinel also has this cool thing
with the map is that Sentinel has areas
where you can duel in the duel game mode
and they're not playable in Dominion so
they're completely out of the map areas
which is nice
Viking village doesn't have it sadly but
it's cool data anyway send them to me
seems like a huge map though with a lot
of access points to each objective as
well as ballistas in the map to shoot
opposing players it did say that the
ballistas will be obviously able to kill
players but it's not as overpowered as
you think there is multiple ways to get
up there and there is a lot of cover so
that you can run there as well so you
won't be shot in the middle of nowhere
next up though we did I showed you with
the Viking village and I get this weird
creepy vibe for me I don't know if you
guys got that as well from the trailer
but I feel that makes it look even
better it's supposed to be a harbor for
the Vikings so that when they go raid a
castle they come get the stuff that they
raid drop it off and then go back for
more and then this rolling ball of death
is activated via a lever within the map
and then according to the devs shinobi
will be the only character in the game
able to outrun the death ball so
obviously using his super sprint so that
it be that's super nice to know but
that's all though for this very small
video once again there's going to be
another video today regarding a new
patch note 1.11 coming soon with tons of
info I'll share with you guys so stay
tuned for that today I hope you guys did
enjoy though leave a like if you did for
that double upload and the triple up
load coming tonight and if you're new
from and if you're new subscribe for
that new foreigner content coming in
last couple days my recent video is
popping up on screen and with that I
hope you guys have a great rest of your
day and I'll see you later today peace
out